[Music]  sorry yelling at me like what you have  serious anger issues on Wednesday a  social media firestorm erupted between  Rob Kardashian and blac Chyna but on  Thursday the 29 year old models seem to  turn her attention toward something new  check out China's mystical new look  chive hair giving us serious unicorn  vibes tones of pink purple blue green  and yellow all complemented by her  matching rainbow Chanel bag I'm just  happy an eye witness tells ET Chyna was  out in LA for a photo shoot  she smiled for cameras and even snapped  some selfies with fans it was so fast  and it just happened  it seems the mother of two is staying  positive following her public blowout  with Rob psycho what's wrong  mind your business or relax Rob accused  China of cheating and doing drugs while  she clocked back with allegations of  domestic abuse  [Music]